and did it feel like you guys were like
so separate from the world of your
parents because they were living in like
a
more of like a political world well with
everything was
you know we we felt we were included in
everything i was you know
i the first time that i came to
california was for the 1960 convention
and i saw my uncle get inaugurated and
then i
um flew back on the airplane with him
and sat next to him on the plane but my
father would you know my home was in
virginia but at that time
you could get to the justice department
in about um
eight or nine minutes of your driving
fast
and so my father would come home at
night he would talk about
integrating the university of alabama or
you know whatever the
issues of the day what was any you know
we were always included and then we
visited
the white and at the justice department
i
uh one day my uncle invited me
to spend the morning with him in the
white house in the oval office
we were you know we were
part of all of the i
sat behind the couch during the cuban
missile crisis
and you know listen to my our house
was kind of a satellite white house
because my father was the attorney
general and he was the president's chief
advisor
we were a mile away from the cia
headquarters in langley and my
father at that time was um
you know was involved with the trying to
get the cia to behave
and so all of that you know there were
green berets at our house there were
cuban refugees
there was um you know
the entire milieu of that period was
yeah
damn dmv it sounds like you know i mean
it just has it you know it's like
it just sounds like when i was like so
much going on
it was every friday when we were at the
cave
there would be three helicopters that
would land marine helicopters that would
land on our lawn every friday and my
uncle would get off president kennedy
my father was the attorney general my
uncle sarge driver who is the director
of the peace corps my uncle
ted kennedy who was in the senate
already at that time
um and my uncle steve smith who was
chief of staff
and the white house would move to our
house for the weekend
and you know there was always
interesting people there
and um that we had in after 1962 my
uncle developed this very close
relationship
with with khrushchev and the cia
was baffled by khrushchev because
they had never been able to get a spy
into the kremlin there was a mole in the
c.i.a and to this day they don't know
who it was
and every time they got a high-level spy
on the kremlin he would immediately be
killed
because the mall at langley was so they
really had no clue
what khrushchev was like or whether
it was a monolithic the kremlin was
monolithic and everybody was thinking
the same which was kind of the
assumption
and so he came to visit you guys he
never visited us now but he
exchanged um he exchanged letters with
my uncle secretly
he didn't want the kgb or the gru to
find out he was writing my uncle and
he um and my uncle was was again
they both figured out that they were
both at war with the
military and intelligence apparatus with
with
with which they were surrounded oh i see
what you're saying so it's like a
cruise ship had been a war hero
he had uh run the defense of stalingrad
under
stalin stalin had actually tried to
purge him at one point
and the only reason he didn't was
because khrushchev was running a defense
of um of stalingrad
and he couldn't reach him because you
know when hitler was trying to
attack stalingrad which is one of the
worst battles one of the most brutal
battles in human history
and one of the most expansive battles in
terms of human life and khrushchev had
no desire to
go to war his first meeting with my
uncle was a couple of was about a month
after my uncle took office and i met a
geneva
and my uncle went into that meeting with
very high hopes that he could make peace
and they could begin
dismantling the nuclear arsenal on both
sides
a khrushchev had met him very
pugnaciously and had been bombastic
and had given a lecture about
imperialism and said that he was ready
for war and
he was really kind of in his face and my
uncle went home from that meeting very
depressed
and then a year and a half later there
was a confrontation when the
soviets were building the wall in berlin
because they were hemorrhaging people
everybody was trying to get out of east
germany and come on to the western side
which the u.s
controlled and khrushchev built a wall
there
and his joint chiefs of staff saw this
as an opportunity they wanted to go to
war with the russians
they believed that at that point in
history we had the nuclear advantage
the russians would soon catch up with us
so the president's chief of staff wanted
to go to war
well his joint chiefs did okay the
military
and the leaders of the cia
wanted to they wanted it's all they saw
war as inevitable and that the sooner
the better because the us
was at a big military advantage in terms
of its nuclear arsenal at that time
and um and my uncle and khrushchev's
uh joint chiefs were basically in the
same position they were spoiling for a
war
my uncle who was also a veteran and had
you know
had a uh had seen his men die
um had three of his men on his bt boat
killed when it was run over by a
japanese destroyer and then you know he
had been lost at sea for
10 days hiding out on a little island
with the japanese
searching for him and he he mistrusted
the
the brass he had been lied to by alan
dulles
at the very beginning he knew dulles had
lied to him and fired alan dallas
fired the top three guys the cia and no
longer trusted his military
and he realized that he was in the same
boat with
with khrushchev uh in 1962
khrushchev built a wall and
one of jack's generals lucious clay
mounted bulldozer plows on the front of
tanks
and went to push down the wall and the
russians met him on the other side at
checkpoint charlie
with their own squadron of jet tanks and
my uncle sent a secret message to
khrushchev at that point
saying you know please withdraw your
tanks and i promise that
when you do that we will watch ours
within 20 minutes and he said my back is
against the wall i have no place to
retreat
um and my uncle and father believed that
there would be
that there they lived for a lot of their
administration believing that the
military may
commit a coup against them that their
own military
yes the u.s they couldn't trust the cia
because they
yeah they believe that yeah right
exactly their their military
you know it was daniel ellsberg who was
working in the pentagon at that time
said that it was
you know that at the the atmosphere in
the pentagon was one of kudeta
of rebellion that they believe that um
the fact that my uncle had not gone into
cuba and bombed castro during the bay of
pigs which was
two months into his administration and
then he did not
a khrushchev during the during
that confrontation that was evidence
that he was
committing treason against the united
states so they were really war happy at
that time huh
yes and your uncle came in and you're
and that's when your father was attorney
general and they were a little bit more
on the peaceful side of things huh
right or the hopeful side of peace well
they didn't want to go to war
they in fact my uncle said when he was
asked by ben bradley who was one of his
best friends who was the editor of the
washington post what he wanted on
his as his epithet on his tombstone
he said he wanted he kept the peace
and he often said that the president's
principal
job was to keep the nation out of war
who was the better peacekeeper you think
your uncle or your father
when you look back even just like they
were working together at that time i
mean my uncle really
did not want to go to war and my father
ran against the vietnam war
and you know um yeah there's a lot of
famous pictures of him and stuff when he
was running
uh yeah oh
um you want to talk about
yeah good evening good afternoon and
other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one